I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论夏天的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢用Airbnb。我当然知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房，我喜欢早上穿着浴袍走出去喝杯茶，正如你所说的，珍娜，我喜欢更长的缓冲期。是的。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉何马州工作，我们要去探望他，他给我们订了一家非常好的Airbnb，全家人一起住。这样我们就能舒展开来，每个人都能睡得好。然后你会觉得就像在家一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, correct. I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah. Everyone, we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure, for your next
即使你在一个不同的城市。天哪，我才不想和我的整个家人睡在同一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了住普通酒店了。对，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。对，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，真正的冰箱。正如你所知的，我喜欢准备零食。我确实知道这一点。是的，没错。我不想叫客房服务。我希望它们就在手边。没。错。是的。大家，我们大概都是爱用Airbnb的女性，为了你的下一次冒险，为了你的下一次
vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. With the Fizz loyalty program you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Friday Chit Chat with Jenna and Angela and Cassie and Sam. Hey! It's Friday Chit Chat with the office ladies folks. Woohoo!
假期，也许可以考虑一下Airbnb。通过Fizz忠诚度计划，只要拥有移动套餐，你就能获得奖励。你知道的，比如发短信什么的。如果你通过移动套餐没有获得额外流量和折扣等奖励，说明你选错了，快来加入Fizz吧。受条件限制。详情请见fizz.ca。与珍娜、安吉拉、凯西和萨姆的周五闲聊。嘿！这是“办公室女士”的周五闲聊节目，各位。噢吼！
Hi everybody. Welcome to Friday Chit Chat. Welcome to Friday Chit Chat. We've got a few things to chat about. We were feeling chatty today and we thought, why don't we make a whole bonus moment out of it. I feel like this is going to be, if we keep it going, the sort of kind sister to office ladies burn it to the ground. Oh, you think Friday Chit chat gets a little spicy? I'm just saying it's off the cuff.
大家好。欢迎收听周五闲聊。欢迎收听周五闲聊。我们有一些事情要聊聊。我们今天很有倾诉欲，所以我们想，为什么不把它做成一个完整的彩蛋环节呢。我觉得如果我们将这个节目继续做下去，它会成为“办公室女士：烧个精光”的善良姐妹。哦，你觉得周五闲聊节目会变得有点火辣吗？我只是说这是即兴发挥。
It's whatever we're thinking and feeling. Yeah, I have no idea what you're about to say to me. No idea. It's that soothing balm you apply after the burn of? Office ladies burn it to the ground? Yep. Well, eventually, we're just going to come on here as cranky old ladies and burn it to the ground.
这就是我们心里想的、感受到的。对，我完全不知道你接下来要对我说什么。完全不知道。这就是你在经历了“办公室女士：烧个精光”的犀利之后，涂抹的那种舒缓药膏吗？没错。好吧，最终，我们只会以脾气暴躁的老太太身份来到这里，把一切烧个精光。
But right now, we're still feeling a little positive, right? A little peppy with our Friday chit chat. Exactly. Can I tell you guys how my day started as I came into our building? Yeah, please go. Okay, you know how you try to get everything on one trip so you're carrying multiple things?
但现在，我们仍然感觉有点积极，对吧？我们的周五闲聊充满活力。没错。我能跟你们讲讲我今天进大楼时是怎么开始的吗？好的，请讲。好吧，你知道那种你想一次性把所有东西都拿完，所以拿着很多东西的情况吗？
Because God forbid you make two trips to the car, you know what I mean? Well, to be fair, where we park is a bit of a trek. It's a bit of a trek so I have like my laptop, my bag, I have my little office ladies coffee tumbler mug thing and Josh calls me and then I got my phone in the crook of my neck and I'm holding these things and I'm trying to hit the elevator button in the building. Yeah. But like I'm all jammed up and the superintendent of our building goes, hey, hey, hey, come in my elevator. He's like, hey, hey, I'm already in here.
因为老天保佑你可不想跑两趟车，你知道我的意思吧？公平地说，我们停车的地方要走好长一段路。确实要走一段路，所以我拿着我的笔记本电脑、包，我还有那个“办公室女士”咖啡随行杯，然后乔什给我打电话，我就用脖子夹着手机，手里拿着这些东西，试图按大楼的电梯按钮。对。但我被挤得动弹不得，我们大楼的管理员走过来说，嘿，嘿，嘿，进来我的电梯。他说，嘿，嘿，我已经在这儿了。
I'm like, oh, okay. And I pop in. This building has how many floors? 12? I think. I pop in and I'm already running a little late. He's got every single button lit up. No. And he's on a walkie talkie and I'm like, what's happening?
我说，哦，好吧。然后我挤了进去。这栋楼有多少层？12层？我想是的。我挤进去的时候已经有点迟到了。他把每一个楼梯按钮都按亮了。不会吧。他正拿着对讲机，我说，发生什么事了？
And Josh is like, where are you? I'm like, I'm in an elevator, babe. And then he's like, we're testing the elevators today. So we're stopping at every floor. Did he think this would be what you wanted? I don't know. And I was like, what? He was like, hey, lady, in a rush, holding lots of stuff.
乔什问：你在哪儿？我说：我在电梯里呢，宝贝。然后他说：我们今天在测试电梯。所以我们每一层都要停。他觉得你会希望这样吗？我不知道。我说：什么？他说：嘿，女士，赶时间，拿着一堆东西。
I've got a treat for you. I know. You want to stop at every floor with me? And so I was like, Josh, I got to go. And then I said, I need to get off this elevator. And he was like, oh, he goes, I go, he said, what floor are you? And when I told him my floor number, he goes, oh, I'm so sorry. Yeah.
我给你准备了个惊喜。我知道。你想陪我每一层都停吗？所以我说：乔什，我得挂了。然后我说：我得离开这个电梯。他说：哦，他说，我说，他问：你在几楼？当我告诉他我的楼层号时，他说：哦，非常抱歉。对。
So then I got off at level two, which I've never been on in this building. And is it special or different? Yeah. How did it compare? It looked just the same, but a fella had his door open. You know, all of our doors are closed. We go in our office, we shut the door. Yeah.
于是我在二楼下了电梯，我以前从来没去过这栋楼的二楼。它很特别还是跟别处不同？对。感觉怎么样？看起来都一样，不过有个家伙把门开着。你知道，我们所有的门都是关着的。我们走进办公室，就把门关上。对。
I don't see it. What was inside? I love an open door. I love an open, I'm so sorry to say, if you live in a house and you have your curtains open, I'm going to look in your house. Are you a peeper? When you're taking a walk, do you look into people's houses too? Especially if it's nighttime and there's light coming from the house? Yeah, I want to see what are you watching on TV? Are you cooking dinner? What's
我看不见。里面有什么？我喜欢敞开的门。我喜欢敞开的……我很抱歉这么说，如果你住在一所房子里，而你的窗帘是开着的，我会往你家里看的。你是个偷窥狂吗？当你散步时，你也会往别人的家里看吗？特别是如果是晚上，屋里有光透出来的时候？对，我想看看你在电视上看什么？你在做晚饭吗？你的
your routine? I'm for it. What was in the door, Angela? A man. A man what? A very tall man. He was sitting down and my first thought was like, his chair is too small for him. Okay. He needs, or it's too low. I'm like, this is a tall man sitting kind of in a little chair. I don't know him. I don't know if I'll ever see him again,
日常生活是怎样的？我支持这个。门里面是什么，安吉拉？一个男人。什么样的男人？一个非常高的男人。他正坐着，我的第一反应是，他的椅子对他来说太小了。好吧。他需要，或者椅子太低了。我想，这是一个高个子男人坐在一个小椅子上。我不认识他。我不知道以后还会不会见到他，
but I'm gonna wonder about him in his chair. It's gonna be hard for me not to stop on the second floor on the way out today. See if his door's open. I'm picturing you in a being John Malkovich situation. Mm. Yeah, yeah. So that was the energy I brought in this morning and I was like, Jenna, you and I,
但我会一直好奇他和他那把椅子的事。今天我出去的时候，很难克制不在二楼停下来看看的冲动。看看他的门是不是开着的。我脑海中浮现出你在《傀儡人生》里的情景。嗯。对，对。这就是我今天早上的状态，我说：珍娜，你和我……
she was like, save it for Friday Chit Chat. I've got another question for you, lady. Okay. For Friday Chit Chat. Do you wanna share your beef with Ben Stiller? Oh no. Yes. Yeah, lay it on her.
她当时说：留着在周五闲聊时说吧。女士，我还有另一个问题要问你。好的。关于周五闲聊。你想分享一下你对本·斯蒂勒的不满吗？哦，不。是的。没错，向她开炮。
Oh no you guys. I don't know him at all. I'm sure he's a lovely person. I know him well and I love him and he is a lovely person. Okay. Well, I guess they're doing the Severance podcast in our same studio, right? We found this out. They are.
哦，不，你们。我一点也不认识他。我确信他是个可爱的人。我很了解他，我很喜欢他，他确实是个可爱的人。好吧。好吧，我想他们是在和我们同一个录音室制作《人生切割术》播客，对吧？我们发现了这一点。是的。
Ben Stiller and Adam Scott have a Severance podcast. Yes. And they record it in our studio. And every time we come in to record now, my headphones don't fit me. They're so big. You've decided that the reason they're big is because Ben Stiller is widening them for his head. And this is like, this sounds so mean. But every time I put them on, they don't fit. I'm like, damn it, Ben and your big head. And then I have to readjust them. Ben, I don't
本·斯蒂勒和亚当·斯科特有一个《人生切割术》播客。是的。而且他们是在我们的录音室录制的。每次我们现在进来录音时，我的耳机都不合适。它们太大了。你断定耳机变大的原因是因为本·斯蒂勒为了他的大头把它们撑大了。这听起来太刻薄了。但每次我戴上它们，它们都不合适。我说：该死的本，还有你的大头。然后我不得不重新调整它们。本，我
know if your head is big. I just, your hair is a little poofy. So I, I'm assuming the headphones have to fit over your poofy hair Also, I feel like Adam Scott's head is much bigger That's gotta be Adam Scott. I know why are we blaming it on Ben? Oh, I don't know cuz his hair's so poofy My hair is poofy and I have a regular size head. I don't know one of them has a big head I don't know one of them sits in my seat. But I hear great things about Sepphras. You haven't seen it? No, Josh has watched it and he wants me to watch it
不知道你的头是不是很大。我只是觉得你的头发有点蓬松。所以我猜测耳机必须戴在你蓬松的头发上。另外，我觉得亚当·斯科特的头要大得多。那肯定是亚当·斯科特。我不知道为什么我们要怪本？哦，我不知道，因为他的头发太蓬松了。我的头发也很蓬松，而我有一个正常大小的头。我不知道，他们俩其中一个头很大。我不知道，他们俩其中一个人坐在我的座位上。不过我听到了很多关于《人生切割术》的好评。你没看过吗？没有，乔什看过，他希望我和他一起看，但我还没看呢。
with him, but I haven't watched it yet. Oh, I love it. Speaking of a whole world, I mean, you love whole worlds and like alternate realities. Josh said I would love it. He wants me to start watching it, but we have a few other things he wants me to watch. There's a queue.
哦，我太喜欢了。说到一个完整的世界，我是说，你喜欢完整世界和另类现实。乔什说我会喜欢的。他想让我开始看，但我们还有其他一些他想让我看的东西。排着队呢。
Well, he really wanted me to watch Black Doves. Oh, I haven't heard of that. What is that about? It's so good. It might be Black Dove Singular. I don't know. You know how I do that. Sometimes I pluralize things.
好吧，他真的很想让我看《黑鸽》。哦，我没听说过那个。那是讲什么的？太棒了。可能单数是《黑鸽》。我不知道。你知道我平时是怎么样的。有时我喜欢把词复数化。
We do. It's so good. It's got, Keira Knightley is in it. It is so good. It's got, Keira Knightley is in it. It is so good. It's a TV show? I'm obsessed, yes. It's set in the UK and I don't want to give too much away. It's really good.
我们都这样。太棒了。里面有凯拉·奈特莉。太棒了。里面有凯拉·奈特莉。太棒了。这是一部电视剧？我迷上了，是的。故事背景在英国，我不想剧透太多。真的很棒。
She's phenomenal in it. I mean, I think Keira Knightley is all the sell I need. Yeah, but the whole cast is fantastic. Guess what I watched the beginning of the other day with my lunch. Oh, what did you watch on your lunch break? Did you not see the office lady's text thread? I'm already livid. I'm clenching my fists. Wait, I did see it. I didn't know you watched that on your lunch.
她在里面的表演无与伦比。我的意思是，我觉得有凯拉·奈特莉就足够吸引我了。对，但整个演员阵容都棒极了。猜猜我前几天吃午饭时看了什么开头。哦，你在午休时看了什么？你没看到办公室女士的群聊信息吗？我已经气炸了。我气得攥紧了拳头。等等，我确实看到了。我不知道你是午饭时看的。
How did I miss that? That is not a lunch watch. Kat, thank you. What a random time to watch this. How did you watch that on your lunch? How did I miss that? That is not a lunch watch. Yes, thank you. What a random time to watch this. I knew the moment I was getting these texts, you were watching it while cleaning or doing something in the back. I knew the chances of you sitting down
我怎么会错过那个？那可不是午饭时看的东西。卡特，谢谢你。看这个的时间可真随机。你怎么会在午饭时看那个？我怎么会错过那个？那可不是午饭时看的东西。是的，谢谢。看这个的时间可真随机。我知道我收到这些信息的时候，你一定是在后台打扫卫生或者干别的什么的时候看的。我知道你坐在那里，
with a blanket and a bucket of popcorn and pressing play were zero. Tell them. Tell them what you watched while having lunch. Lord of the Rings. Hey. How much did you watch? Yeah, how much?
盖着毯子，捧着一桶爆米花，按播放键的可能性为零。告诉他们。告诉他们你吃午饭时看了什么。魔戒。嘿。你看了多少？对，看了多少？
15, 20 minutes? How long does it take you to eat your sandwich? It was a pasta. Oh. It was a factor meal, by the way. We're not sponsored by factor, but I think we should be, because I really like their food.
15、20分钟？你吃三明治要花多长时间？是一盘意大利面。哦。顺便说一句，是Factor速食餐。我们没有赞助商Factor，但我觉得我们应该有，因为我真的很喜欢他们的食物。
We would like to be. Um, I got to... Tell me the time code. I don't know. That Gandalf guy showed up in a wagon. That Gandalf. In a wagon? What?
我们很乐意。嗯，我得……告诉我时间码。我不知道。那个叫甘道夫的家伙坐着马车出现了。那个甘道夫。坐着马车？什么？
Isn't that his name? He shows up to the Shire. Yes. Yes, that's his name. It's Gandalf. Yeah, and he talked to the... What's he do? What are you going to say?
那不是他的名字吗？他来到了夏尔。是的。是的，那就是他的名字。是甘道夫。对，他跟……他干嘛呢？你打算说什么？
Bo Bo Baggins? Bilbo. Bilbo. Yeah. What do you do? What are you going to say? Bobo Baggins? Bilbo. Bilbo. Bilbo. Bilbo Baggins. I also would have accepted Bobo Baggins. I like Bobo. This is like how you talked about Carl on Game of Thrones.
博博·巴金斯？比尔博。比尔博。对。你干嘛呢？你打算说什么？博博·巴金斯？比尔博。比尔博。比尔博。比尔博·巴金斯。我也能接受博博·巴金斯。我喜欢博博。这就像你谈论《权力的游戏》里的卡尔一样。
Here was my thing. Guys, I, oh no, embracing myself, Sam. Okay, what I texted on the text thread was like, I'm seven and a half minutes into this movie and all I have is just like a narrated backstory. You said there's a lot of talking. Montage of the lore. It's just like seven and a half minutes of lore which
我的意思是。伙计们，我，哦不，我要做好心理准备了，萨姆。好的，我在群聊里发的是，这部电影我看了七分半钟，结果全都是旁白背景故事。你说有很多对话。传说背景的蒙太奇。这就像七分半钟的背景传说，而
again you're about to if you watched all three you're about to watch ten hours of Lord of the Rings you can handle seven minutes here's I need a lesson before the movie starts here she goes I am out I'm out like no can't this information be spread out through plot and conversation? It's being given to you by someone speaking it at the beginning. But a narrator, it's just a narration. And there's so much to remember. Do you realize how many people and lands
话说回来，如果你看了全部三部，你马上就要看十个小时的《魔戒》，你连七分钟都撑不下来吗？我需要在电影开始前上课。她来了，我不看了。我不看了，不行，这些信息难道不能通过剧情和对话散落开来吗？这是由一个在开场时说话的人直接告诉你的。但那是旁白，只是叙述而已。而且有那么多东西要记。你知道有多少人和土地吗？
and like, these people don't like these people. And then I'm like, what's the difference between the, what are they elves, hobbits and the other people? And then the, I don't, oh. And then also like the ring just fell into the bottom of a lake and nobody looked for it for how long? We just let it sit there.
还有，这些人不喜欢那些人。然后我就想，精灵、霍比特人和其他人之间有什么区别？然后，我不知道，哦。然后还有那枚戒指掉到了湖底，这么久都没人去找它？我们就让它在那儿待着。
People have been looking for it for how long? We just let it sit there. People have been looking for it for a long time. And then that guy finds it just by happenstance, but it doesn't turn him evil. He just loses it again. What? Or the Baggins person finds it. It does turn him evil. It does turn him evil.
人们找了它多久了？我们就让它在那儿待着。人们找了它很长时间。然后那家伙阴差阳错地找到了它，但它并没有让他变邪恶。他只是又把它弄丢了。什么？或者巴金斯那家伙找到了它。它确实让他变邪恶了。它确实让他变邪恶了。
You have to watch if you watch more than 20 minutes of it. Okay, okay, okay, fine. Listen, I'm so sorry. People love Lord of the Rings. I might finish it because I will say after that part that I just was, you know, was like an itchy blanket to me that I was enduring. You hate learning new stuff about worlds.
如果你看超过20分钟的话你就知道了。好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。听着，我很抱歉。《魔戒》很多人喜欢。我可能会把它看完，因为我要说的是，在那一部分之后，我刚刚觉得，你知道的，对我来说就像一件扎人的毯子，我在苦苦忍受。你讨厌了解关于世界的全新设定。
Like, I just, you just hate it. And I'm gonna call bulls**t. It doesn't matter if it's in narration. It doesn't matter if characters are living it. You don't want to learn the new world. And yet I love Severance. Love it. Okay.
就像我说的，你就是讨厌。我要戳穿这个牛皮。这跟是不是旁白无关。这跟是不是角色正在经历也无关。你就是不想去了解新世界。然而我却爱惨了《人生切割术》。爱惨了。好吧。
What's that? I don't know. What's the difference? But you're gonna stick with it, Lord of the Rings? You're gonna stick with it? I'm gonna stick with it because once the two people started talking to each other, they're such good actors. Yeah.
那是啥？我不知道。有什么区别？但你要坚持看下去吗，《魔戒》？你会坚持看下去吗？我会坚持看下去，因为一旦那两个人开始交谈，他们的演技太好了。对。
And now I'm interested. Now I'm sort of like, oh, what's going to happen now that he has this ring? I was intrigued. My precious. Oh, boy. Do you know what that means? I mean, I think Silence of the Lambs, but no.
现在我感兴趣了。现在我有点觉得，哦，他有了这枚戒指之后会发生什么呢？我被吸引了。我的宝贝。哦，天哪。你知道那是什么意思吗？我的意思是，我想到了《沉默的羔羊》，但不是。
Yes, it is Silence of the Lambs. Let's let her think that. That's exactly what it is. OK. There's a movie that crosses over with Silence of the Lambs. There's kind of a random guest star by Anthony Hopkins. Does anybody else have anything else to say for Friday Chit Chat?
是的，就是《沉默的羔羊》。让她这么认为吧。完全就是那个。好的。有一部电影和《沉默的羔羊》有交集。安东尼·霍普金斯有一个相当随机的客串。还有人对周五闲聊有什么要说的吗？
I've been watching The Pit on HBO. It's Noah Weill is his name. It's like a procedural show, kind of like ER. But it's just really, really well done in the way, so like one season takes place over like two days in the hospital, so when one episode picks up, it's like right where it left off on the previous one. It's really, really well done and really, really fascinating.
我在HBO上看《急诊室的故事》。男主角叫诺亚·怀尔。有点像医疗剧，有点像《急诊室的故事》。但它真的非常非常出色，比如第一季的故事发生在医院的两天时间里，所以当一集开始时，它就像上一集结束的地方无缝衔接。真的是非常非常棒，也非常非常迷人。
We just started it. Okay. It's great. I've only seen the first episode and it's so good. Is it Noah Wiley? I think so. I think I said it wrong. He was on ER. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Friends, I watched Love is Blind, Season 8.
我们刚开始看。好吧。太棒了。我只看了第一集，就觉得太好看了。是诺亚·怀尔吗？我想是的。我可能说错了。他演过《急诊室的故事》。对。是的。对。是的。朋友们，我看了《爱情盲白》第八季。
Oh, nice. Wait, is Love is Blind... Again, I refuse to believe that your brain can handle Love is Blind and not Lord of the Rings. Thank you. It's in Love is Blind, it's kind of brain rot, isn't it? Is it like two people, oh no, people are gonna come for me now.
哦，不错。等等，《爱情盲白》……再说一次，我拒绝相信你的大脑能看懂《爱情盲白》却看不懂《魔戒》。谢谢。看《爱情盲白》简直就像大脑腐蚀，不是吗？是不是两个人，哦不，人们现在要来攻击我了。
Oh no, it's brain rot. It's brain rot. It's okay. It is stimulating, intelligent television. It's intelligent television. No, it is people in pods, they can't see each other, they get mixed and matched on these blind dates, and then they have to fall in love
哦不，这是大脑腐蚀。这是大脑腐蚀。没关系。这是富有启发性的、智能的电视剧。这是智能电视剧。不，就是一群人在隔间里，他们看不见彼此，在这些盲约中被随机配对，然后他们必须在
without ever seeing each other. Although my one complaint is, ultimately everyone's hot. There's not... The casting is like... You're not... There's not like a big chance that like you're not gonna be attracted to each other. I have a question. I have a question.
从未见过面的情况下坠入爱河。虽然我的唯一抱怨是，最终每个人都很火辣。没有……演员阵容就像是……你不会……你们不太可能会对彼此不来电。我有问题。我有问题。
What? Because I haven't seen it. Is it... You said they go on blind dates, but they can't see each other? That's right. They get sequestered. I have a question. I don't know. I have a question. What? Because I haven't seen it. Is it, you said they go on blind dates, but they can't see each other? That's right. They get sequestered. So there's like a girl's dorm and a boy's dorm.
什么？因为我没看过。是不是……你刚才说他们去盲约，但他们看不见彼此？没错。他们被隔离了。我有问题。我不知道。我有问题。什么？因为我没看过。是不是，你刚才说他们去盲约，但他们看不见彼此？没错。他们被隔离了。所以有一个女生宿舍和一个男生宿舍。
And then there's these pods. And you go into a pod and there's like a scrim between you. You each have a couch and you sit in there and you just have dates. And you can eat food and you chit chat And you talk about your lives and if you fall in love They open the scrim. No first you have to get engaged What you have to get engaged before they open the scrim? Oh, I hate they don't even open the scrim You just you get engaged then you see each other
然后有这些隔间。你走进一个隔间，里面有一层薄纱幕布。你们每个人都有一个沙发，坐在里面约会。你们可以吃东西，闲聊，谈论你们的生活，如果你坠入爱河，他们就会拉开幕布。不，首先你们必须订婚。什么？在拉开幕布之前你们必须订婚？哦，我讨厌这样，他们甚至不拉开幕布，你直接就订婚了，然后才能见到对方。
Then you go on a honeymoon you go on a vacation together with all the other couples who got engaged. So now there's a bunch of hot people on a vacation. So and they've never touched. They've never touched. Never touched, but you're engaged. Yeah. I have another question. What?
然后你们去度蜜月，和其他所有订婚的情侣一起去度假。所以现在有一群火辣的人在一起度假。而且他们从未碰触过。从未碰触过。从未碰触过，但你们已经订婚了。对。我还有个问题。什么？
When they go on this group. Vacation? Honeymoon? Yeah, it's like they go on a vacation and then after the vacation, they go back to their city of origin, and they live together. And then they get married in six weeks. Oh my god.
当他们去这个集体……度假？蜜月？对，就像他们去度假，度假结束后，他们回到各自的家乡，同居。然后在六周后结婚。哦，天哪。
Oh, wow. Or not. This is so much. Or they don't get married. I have a question. What? When they go on this group honeymoon, is that what it is? Mm-hmm.
哦，哇。或者不结婚。这也太疯狂了吧。或者他们不结婚。我有问题。什么？当他们去这个集体蜜月时，是这样的吗？嗯嗯。
Yeah. So they're already married? No, they're just engaged. Oh, so they go on a group engagement vacation. Correct. And there's multiple pairs of newly engaged people who've never seen each other. Right, yes.
对。所以他们已经结婚了？不，他们只是订婚了。哦，所以他们去参加集体订婚度假。没错。有多对从未见过面的新订婚的情侣。对，没错。
That travel together to a destination. And they're all attractive. Hook up? Well, some of them have been talking to other people and they're like, I thought I was gonna pick Angela, but I ended up getting engaged to Jenna. Now I see Angela. And I'm much more attracted to her if I'm being honest.
一起去一个目的地旅行。而且他们都很有魅力。然后勾搭上？嗯，有些人一直在和别人聊天，他们会想，我本来以为我会选安吉拉，但我最后却和珍娜订婚了。现在我看到了安吉拉。说实话，我对他更有吸引力。
So then there's weird crossover and then shenanigans and hookups. You got it. With not the person you potted with. You got it, lady. Also, that is the exact amount of time it would have taken you to pay attention to Lord of the Rings. That amount of information.
所以这里面会有奇怪的交叉，然后就会有恶作剧和勾搭。完全正确。和不是跟你在一个隔间的人。完全正确，女士。另外，这刚好就是你注意到《魔戒》所需要的时间。那么多信息。
It took seven minutes. Okay, touche, touche. I do have to play for you guys. My friend Nikki got me a birthday gift. Nikki and I watch Love is Blind together. Did she get you a cameo? She got me a cameo. My last birthday, she got me gold wine glasses. Because they only drink out of gold stemware.
只花了七分钟。好吧，触类旁通，触类旁通。我确实得给你们放一段。我的朋友妮基送了我一份生日礼物。妮基和我一起看《爱情盲白》。她给你买了一个名人视频祝福吗？她给我买了一个名人视频祝福。我上个生日，她送了我金色高脚酒杯。因为他们只用金色高脚杯喝酒。
I remember that, I remember that. Okay, this year, this is what I got from my friend Nikki. I hope they don't drink wine out of cold stemware. Hi Jenna, first of all, happy belated birthday. And I hear that this actually isn't just any birthday. It is a very special birthday because you just kicked cancer's ass. Yeah girl, you did that shit. Honestly, I can't think of anything more impressive.
我记得那个，我记得那个。好吧，今年，这是我从朋友妮基那里收到的礼物。希望他们不用高脚杯喝冷酒。嗨，珍娜，首先，祝你迟来的生日快乐。我听说这其实不是普通的生日。这是一个非常特别的生日，因为你刚刚把癌症打得落花流水。是的，女孩，你做到了。老实说，我想不出有什么比这更让人印象深刻的了。
That's definitely more impressive than surviving love is blind because I do actually know a thing or two about surviving really interesting situations to say the least. You are clearly so much stronger than any of the men that I had to deal with on Love is Blind which, let's be honest, the bar is in hell but real recognizes real. If anyone deserves to celebrate, it's you, Queen. So happy, happy birthday. I hope this next year brings you so much happiness, so much health, emotionally intelligent men, and supportive sisters. Bye. That was Madison, y'all. Oh, I don't know who she is, but I think that's a great, great message. Who is Madison? Is she the Gandalf of Lord of the Love is Blind?
这绝对比在《爱情盲白》中幸存下来更令人印象深刻，因为我对在至少可以说非常有趣的情况中幸存下来略知一二。你显然比我在《爱情盲白》中不得不应付的任何男人都要坚强得多，老实说，标准简直低到了地狱，但英雄识英雄。如果有人值得庆祝，那就是你，女王。祝你生日快乐，快乐快乐。我希望新的一年给你带来无尽的快乐、健康、情商高的男人和支持你的姐妹们。拜拜。那是麦迪逊，各位。哦，我不知道她是谁，但我觉得这是一条非常、非常棒的信息。麦迪逊是谁？她是《魔戒》里的甘道夫吗？
Lord of Love is Blind. Lord of the Blind. I don't know, because I don't know what Gandalf's role is. He's the wizard. No, but she's just a super cool chick. I liked her message. Who's really rad, and I couldn't believe it. I responded to this cameo how I imagine any person responds to a cameo.
《爱情魔戒》。《盲白之王》。我不知道，因为我不知道甘道夫的角色是什么。他是巫师。不，但她只是个超级酷的女孩。我很喜欢她的信息。她真的很酷，我简直不敢相信。我回复这个名人祝福的方式，我想就像任何人回复名人祝福的方式一样。
When she said my name, I was like, oh, this must be random. And then she's like, you kicked cancer's ass. I'm like, she's talking about me. Yeah, that's awesome. But she said the bar is hell. What does that mean? That means I think- The bar is so low.
当她念出我的名字时，我想，哦，这一定是随机的。然后她说：你把癌症打得落花流水。我说：她在说我呢。对，太棒了。但她说标准在地狱。那是什么意思？这意味着我觉得——标准太低了。
The bar is so low. In the pods. Okay, well I had all of a sudden this flash that they have a bar with the theme of hell or something on the show. No, you've gone back to like Lord of the Rings. I did, I did. I went back.
标准太低了。在隔间里。好吧，我突然有一种闪回，觉得他们在节目里有一个以地狱为主题的酒吧什么的。不，你又回到了《魔戒》的节奏。我确实，我确实。我又回去了。
You've gone back to fantasy. A show I'm watching right now is called Offline Love. Okay. It's a Japanese reality TV show, but it takes place in Nice, France. What? Yeah. Layers. Where do I watch this?
你又回到了奇幻世界。我现在看的一个节目叫《离线之爱》。好吧。这是一个日本真人秀电视节目，但拍摄地点在法国尼斯。什么？对。层层叠叠。我在哪里可以看到这个？
On Netflix. Okay. And it's five guys, five girls, single, and they just get dropped off in Nice and they don't have their phones. They just have a little guidebook for the town and they're exploring the town and they run into each other. And then they maybe go on dates and it just feels like fate because they're like away from home, they don't have cell phones.
在网飞上。好吧。节目里有五个男生，五个女生，都是单身，他们被直接空投到尼斯，没有手机。他们只有一本关于这个小镇的小册子，他们在探索小镇时偶遇。然后他们可能会去约会，感觉就像命中注定一样，因为他们远离家乡，没有手机。
How do they find each other? They just like happen to like walk into a thrift store and they see one of them holding the guidebook and they're like, oh my God, are you doing the show? And they're like, I am. And they're like, are you hungry? Do you want to go to a cafe together? That sounds so sweet.
他们是怎么找到彼此的？他们只是碰巧走进一家二手店，看到其中一个人拿着小册子，然后他们会说：天哪，你在参加这个节目吗？对方会说：我是。然后他们会说：你饿吗？你想一起去咖啡馆吗？听起来太甜了。
It's like a shared experience. And being a fish out of water is what then kind of bonds them. Yeah, exactly. And then have you seen romances bloom? Starting to, yeah. OK, I think I could get more behind that than Love is Blind. Yeah, it's very like really no drama.
这就像是一种共同的经历。身处陌生环境正是将他们联系在一起的纽带。对， exatamente。然后你看到浪漫情愫萌芽了吗？开始有了，是的。好吧，我觉得我更能接受这个而不是《爱情盲白》。对，非常真实，几乎没有抓马。
Oh, I like that. Yeah, it's making me really no drama. Oh, I like that. Yeah, it's making me want to go to France. Well, you get travel and then you get the kind of like love connection part too. Yeah, yeah. It's like when you go to like another city somewhere and you randomly run into someone you know and you get way more excited about seeing them in that city
哦，我喜欢这样。对，真的几乎没有抓马。哦，我喜欢这样。对，这让我想去法国了。嗯，你既能旅游，又能体验那种恋爱连结的部分。对，对。就像你去外地的某个城市，偶然碰到一个熟人，你在那个城市见到他们时，会比在你的家乡
than you probably would in your hometown. You're like, oh my god! Hey! Yes, you're right. We're both in Ohio! Oh my god, what are you doing in Ohio? I'm in Ohio! While we're on the topic of no drama love shows, has anyone seen Love on the Spectrum? Yes. That's an incredible show. We've talked about this on the pod, have we not? Oh really? Because you love it, Angela. I love it. And you know, I just, the pod, have we not? Oh, really? Because you love it, Angela. I love it.
见到他们时兴奋得多。你会说：天哪！嘿！是的，你说的对。我们都在俄亥俄州！天哪，你在俄亥俄州干嘛？我在俄亥俄州！既然我们在聊无抓马的恋爱节目，有人看过《非典型爱情》吗？看过。那是一部不可思议的节目。我们在播客里聊过这个，不是吗？哦，真的吗？因为你很喜欢，安吉拉。我很喜欢。你知道，我只是……在播客里聊过，不是吗？哦，真的吗？因为你很喜欢，安吉拉。我很喜欢。
And you know, I just, the parents, when the parents share, I just cry my eyes out. They're so proud of their kids, yeah. Also makes me want to go to Sydney, Australia. Yes, yeah. Because it's so beautiful. That's the season I watched. OK.
你知道，我只是，当父母们分享时，我总是感动得泪流满面。他们为自己的孩子感到骄傲，是的。这也让我想去澳大利亚悉尼。是的，对。因为那里太美了。那是那一季我看过的。好吧。
Oh, all right. Well, I didn't realize we were going to make a viewing list today, but I'm here for it. You don't know what you're going to get on Friday Chit Chat. You. You don't know what you're gonna get on Friday Chit Chat. You sure don't. Well everyone, that was your Friday Chit Chat. Yeah. We might be popping on from time to time
哦，好吧，我没意识到我们今天要列一个观看清单，但我很乐意。你永远不知道在周五闲聊里会听到什么。你。你永远不知道在周五闲聊里会听到什么。你绝对猜不到。好了，各位，这就是你们的周五闲聊。对。我们可能会不时冒出来
to chat with you. Friday Chit Chat, I like it. Yay. It's like journaling out loud. Can we hear that song again going out? Oh yeah, sure. Sure. I can't remember how we did it. Well let's see, it'll be interesting. Sure. I can't remember how we did it.
和你们聊聊天。周五闲聊，我喜欢。耶。就像大声写日记。我们能再听一遍结尾的那首歌吗？哦，好的，当然。当然。我不记得我们是怎么弄的了。好吧，让我们看看，这会很有趣。当然。我不记得我们是怎么弄的了。
Well, let's see. It'll be interesting. Tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, Woo woo! Something like that. Perfect, love you. Maybe we'll be back another Friday, maybe with a proper song next time. See you then. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
好吧，让我们看看。这会很有趣。哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒丹尼斯。办公室女士由奥德赛出品，
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾insley·布巴科。奥德赛的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。办公室女士由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubberree》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。